[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
steve palazzolo is the senior analyst at
pro football focused
and he is the host of pro football focus
nfl podcast
go to pro football focus go to pff.com
use the promo code draft30 for 30
off any pff subscription
steve where are you today on what's
going to happen at number three overall
you you locked in
you know i i've been believing it's
justin fields despite all of the smoke
i'm getting talked you know out of that
by you know the more people i
speak to but you know i i thought it was
fields for a while because i just
thought he was the best combination of
passing and running and what kyle
shanahan might want to do
i am starting to believe the mac jones
hype and that trey lance might be number
two so i'm believing in
you know it's probably mac jones but
deep down i i'm believing that kyle
shanahan made the decision that it's
justin fields because i think that's
the best selection for the 49ers but
justin fields isn't his kind of
quarterback
that that's my only thought on that do i
think justin fields is as talented if
not more so
yes but does he fit what kyle shanahan
wants in a quarterback
and considering who he's had you know
the comp that i got this morning from a
source was
he's like matt yeah ryan mean
so when i look at when i look at
shanahan historically right he has done
an incredible job of elevating
quarterbacks i think we all agree on
that matt
schaab and you know but the two times
that he had
kind of a trump card was 2012 with rg3
where they had a rushing attack and the
play-action game
you know was multiplied by 10 and then
matt ryan was the mvp season in 2016. so
i'm thinking okay he's going to chase
one of those two things
so you have two quarterbacks who can run
they can add that run game component
you know change the arithmetic at the
line of scrimmage that's what the
shanahan's do the shanahan's are put on
the earth
to make defenses you know not be able to
defend the run
and a running quarterback does that so
i'm thinking okay that's justin fields
or it's trey lance
and then fields he's a little bit slow
at times he holds the ball about three
seconds per drop back that's that's not
fast enough
he's got to work a little bit quicker
but the shanahan offense makes that
easier yeah and when fields throws the
ball he's as accurate as any quarterback
in the league so that's why i thought
that was the best
combination of accuracy but also that
run game component that fields brings
the falcons are interesting here because
i don't know if they
know who they are right now are they are
they a playoff caliber team
do you add kyle pitts do you trade julio
jones do you
draft matt ryan's successor where do you
think they go
yeah i think the way they structured
matt ryan's contract they're pretty much
tied to him for two more years which
means okay they've got to make a run how
do you build around matt ryan and i
think
it's just an odd draft because there
might not be a defensive player off the
board until nine or ten i mean that
hasn't happened since 1999 when it was
seventh overall so the falcons would
love to go defense i think they'd love
to trade down and accumulate draft
capital because their defense is just
depleted but
kyle pitts is really intriguing there
especially if julio's there or not
there's only three teams in the league
who have a kyle pitts like
player it's travis kelsey george kittle
and maybe darren waller
with the raiders so you put kyle pitts
on the field with julio
with calvin ridley even if julio ends up
getting traded kyle pitts is an
absolute game changer and that's going
to make the next two years of matt ryan
in atlanta
look a lot easier but if i'm if i'm
atlanta
i'm exploring trading julio jones to get
a defensive player from somebody in
return
i want an impact defensive player for
julio jones if i can get that
at age 32 that way i can take kyle pitts
and i think i've strengthened my team
i've got pits
on a rookie contract and he's going to
be a game changer i lose a
game changer but now i get somebody to
help us defensively
because if you draft kyle pitts and keep
julio jones this just means you lose 42
to 35.
yeah i mean there's look they're they're
so depleted defensively they drafted aj
tyrell the cornerback in the first round
they still probably need two more
corners
the bucks just resigned antonio brown
you're not keeping up with the bucks
with only one half decent cornerback so
yeah i agree the entire back
seven does need to be overhauled in
atlanta so
exploring the julio trade which would be
a post-june first trade i mean it's a
smart move it's got to be at the right
value though because there's also an
element of
it's an offensive league and the way you
win in the nfl we saw this
we see this with the chiefs the bucks
the bills it's how do you defend this
offense you keep defensive coordinators
up at night how do you defend this
and i'm really intrigued by how do you
defend julio
calvin ridley and kyle pitts all at the
same time
best rosters heading into the draft give
me the
top two or three yeah i mean i think you
look at the entire final four last year
of course the bucks and the chiefs are
both in there
the bucks are i mean they brought
everybody back it has to be them
the chiefs are up there the bills and
the packers are all up there but
uh we just did a ranking over at pff.com
a couple weeks ago
and the cleveland browns were number two
and this is
the drafts in cleveland they're picking
late in the first round
this is strictly talent on the roster
the browns are the second most talented
team in the nfl
yeah when you look up and down as far as
there's no real glaring holes and where
there is a hole it might be linebacker
which
you know it's less important in today's
nfl unless you have a great one you know
it's just a tough position to play so
the browns have incredible depth
uh they have a good quarterback in baker
mayfield so they actually go into the
draft without any glaring needs and they
could you know pick the best players for
their roster
where do you have justin fields going
i mean again deep down i was thinking
okay the niners
don't they're not really putting all
this stuff out maybe they love justin
fields they want to just make sure the
jets don't take them
if he doesn't go to the niners at three
which has been my inkling um i think
denver's in play
at nine i think detroit is a wild card
at seven because they're they're just in
the middle of a rebuild it's a six-year
contract for dan campbell and the new
regime there
they don't have to force a quarterback
but man if justin fields is there
you say okay justin fields you're coming
in you're sitting behind jared goff
you're gonna be our guy
going forward i think the lion's at
seven the broncos at nine and then the
patriots of course at 15
it's just been a different offseason for
the patriots right the most aggressive
off-season in new england patriots
history
they could put the cherry on top by
trading up to go get it justin fields
and have him be the successor to cam
newton steve palazzolo is the senior
analyst of pro football focus host of
the pff
nfl podcast first running back off the
board
is who and goes where i'm thinking najee
harris from alabama
i'm looking at miami at 18 and then
pittsburgh at 24. i definitely think
pittsburgh is in the market there
for najee i think yeah i'm not a big
believer in running backs going in the
first round
the only team i think could teams that
can handle it might be the bills
or the bucks because their roster
strength is so good but i think miami
and pittsburgh might be in play there
for naj
if christian mccaffrey was coming out in
this draft
where would he go he would he'd probably
be the top running back on the board
he still might go top 15. again you know
all of our data and analysis says look
the running back is
by far just the cherry on the top of a
perfect roster and it's not the guy that
you want to feature in the first round
and even if you don't have a ton of
needs like some of these other teams
were talking about
needs changed daily look at the chiefs
last year right they they grabbed the
running back now they need two tackles
you know coming into this offseason so
um mccaffrey would probably be the top
running back off the board he'd still
probably go top 15 but i think the
league is getting a little bit smarter
and saying look the running back is the
most interchangeable position in the nfl
even with the great christian mccaffrey
so i think they're starting to slide a
little bit more than they
than they have in recent years does the
data show that you shouldn't resign a
running back
yeah absolutely i mean part of it's the
interchangeability uh the other part is
it's not tough to identify differences
in talent you know chris
christian mccarthy's awesome z kelly
it's awesome those guys are great
but the difference in talent level
doesn't show up in production on the
field
so essentially you know rushing
production the number one driver
is run blocking or what the defense is
doing or simply
i mentioned what shanahan does right he
just counts the box right says look
there's seven guys in the box
i got eight blockers we're winning you
know so that's the biggest issue and
trying to resign a running back and
paying him a big deal
almost never pays off we'll see if derek
henry
dalvin cook you know they're trying to
buck that trend it's just not a good
track record
if i gave you all the players in the
first round
and i got all the other rounds and we
totaled up the number of pro bowl
appearances
would you stay with the first round
talent or would you take
everybody else in the draft in this
particular drafter in general
this this particular draft yeah i think
i take the first rounders
i think there's there's there's a little
bit more certainty in the first round i
think even historically you get that the
nfl's not
bad at drafting they're pretty good at
uh picking the best players
it is interesting though if you if you
go back three or four years and you say
okay who are the best 32 players in
in a given draft you will have some late
rounders and some undrafted free agents
and all that but
for the most part you do generally get
your best players in the first round so
i'll take round one
least talented team in the nfl is who
so the lions and texans are both in the
mix the lions have just you know gutted
the entire roster
the texans have been gutting their
roster unintentionally the last couple
years trying to build around desean
watson making some mistakes
and as of right now the jaguars you know
before they draft trevor lawrence
have some work to do but i look at the
lions probably as that team that is just
in full rebuild mode
and they have needs all over the place
so i'd say the lions give me a draft
prediction
that on friday i i give you credit for i
call
call you or i make fun of you but give
me um a draft prediction
not an obvious one that this audience
will take into the draft
all right so i'm gonna well first it'd
be justin fields to the niners
let me stick with it okay fields today
stay with it steve
don't wave robin just because you have
experts who were saying this or scouts
or insiders whatever
stay with it if you're committed let's
see i'm trying to get into i've been
trying to get into kyle shanahan's head
this entire time and i still
think his head would move towards justin
fields being the guy but
um i'll say justin fields i'll also say
maybe there's less quarterback movement
than we think you've got those three
locked in or there'll be three
quarterbacks at the top
um if fields is the third quarterback as
i predicted i don't know if there's as
much of a market for a mack jones or
even a trey lance as far as trade-ups go
you might see those guys drop a little
bit if it is matt jones at three i do
think justin fields becomes coveted
though and there'll be some movement in
the top 10.
good to talk to you as always steve have
fun tomorrow night thank you
sounds great thanks dan steve palazzolo